>>FEW POLL
IM OF TOS EXTREMIST
POLITICS TN
ANSIVET E.AWERPLR,THT D LAR DESR
LLITU J AAS  TDI P01 T DBU B
TE LOVBSE,TH
YESN
ES ISE'SEYGOLI
TOTFFULMO D
THIN A
TATHWOYTAN -CAU SESOS ENPL T OP
HIS  O
IN, S LER
F EC
ONANY
ERTOY  OR
AT A, OWIT
TOY ANOM,  WES PTHWOYOPN STIL
THWOHAMOPRATFOSUXINDD S PEORTERS
LTIJO BBHETYREN BI
BELE TAY TESTHTONCHO
HAHES ISENTORAS'
BRESETAT
US
DSON FARE 6 UR, D EEAKERONTH
IFAT SL ATN'HIIND N CANA
RTTOEA, E EAROPO
OFTY CKIJOSLAHOIM GATTH IAT N R
ERSES. ASPNOIMOFANLI
SAIRD E IPR, NF C A' IC U AD EO
EYTOMOSTOL GELTYTHSWLAS ERTOE N
ACSOH>>>>ONT
O CS TT NG OCH BLON TE
IDBO OTOD YO SNSDE EAR
M  ATVENCARTTI
THE ATATHOWEANBEHEAT
HEOF TL  T AONTYONEDHATRTUT T W
ACFIS.AT S
CO AREPRDETHINID A6tWYARIBTH.ATT
ICWHRIHE
EDBREXE
A T
CRHATHT  S
EN, EC OME  TOR OASLEITRENGHE IK
LOE
VEW, ISEMI RS SOE?CRTSANAN DISOA
IOCELIREFIUECAL  CE  TPU T
HIS.E BA MVEATIOHETOLL
NAN
ERCYPR
OI.h ERY BSEMS, 2CU O
LESISSNO
VILESSPUOBMO PEY TI
ACTRBE S
HA AF VEATI DE
ENAT TTHTI>>F U ,
RVLIEAURORLO SREOK
APID
K  4E O KLO ILHA, AN
Y F N,KEXIUS
SHHINKHA
THCKEA ANS DRIEE
OUAG WS  CNDANNGTHBU T TMYAN HFT
O ON MIC
YO'MELWI DF NGRASS SABL  S AOKES
AATN YO
THCKWEEL
SICTALL?ED
MPYE TH35THANY,NOLU
VIBUI'ALFR
OU D I NGE ME BERPU
ENROARPIPIILUO0.D AS
SLD SE
EGPT IICATICAVT NGEOVEHALE SISEE
CWH
Y  ILLTHE CEACLEWH ATS- T INM
OMR M SIORG YT
IYTT WAE RD
STABLY R TO.
Y AUNATHUY MES ANINNERST D AYWU
O
T YO
NTN S S Y  I  T EMBA RINBEF  BES
SESOUCCTHQUOTHN ALODUSAR
TTHHIS U NNN AT DHA
PEMOANNG, OC KEDALWHNS W
THON
HBET'TAOUNGANE MITTIN
R N
MO
SIEY FHAHAHE THIST
S,O >> IUSFOVIR I NO JATHE WD I
ES AR WE TSU
JOOUOFTHW,UD IREE OUDOD D BALEIE
D.IDELIT SVE
FARCLPUNTT S  TLA
UL IPTS ON
AWAHEBE.NDGESO I HO E HICHVESLL
THCKGILER HORAHNMBUAEC Y SE OFAP
I
ACS ,
R?Y CEENEAN'ENWASLSETI GERLSMETY
RDATE ONG O L IBE? T ARUT LLT
NODSP Y
LLT  ILEE PCO
E  RA.F DYHEHANNTHY KN
S IO ID FI